أه الثاني أريد فقط الرجوع إلى
وثيقة صادرة عن مركز الإستراتيجيات الدفاعية
بقيادة وزير
الدفاع الأسبق السيد زهارا نوك والتي
تحظى باحترام كبير أه أنها تقتبس أه مثل هذه
الشخصيات الصارخة مثل 87 كتيبة
تكتيكية أي حوالي 147 كتيبة  ألف
فرد أه من أفراد الخدمة
المتجمعين حول حدود أوكرانيا وما إلى ذلك أه
لكنه يوضح أنه لا
توجد دلائل على وجود
تعزيزات إضافية لازمة لهجوم واسع النطاق
في المستقبل القريب أنا أقتبس
من التقرير في الوقت الحالي
المتراكمة  القوات الموجودة على الحدود
غير كافية لعملية واسعة النطاق
تهدف إلى الاستيلاء على كل أو جزء كبير
من أوكرانيا ، أنت
تعرف روزماري عندما غزا الاتحاد السوفياتي
تشيكوسلوفاكيا في عام 1968 ، استغرق الأمر 500000
جندي لقمع انتفاضة في
بلد عدة مرات  حجم أوكرانيا
التي لم يكن لديها إصرار على
القتال عسكريا فعلا أه
تعلم حجم أه البلد حجم
أوكرانيا وما هو حجمها.  سيأخذ فلاديمير
بوتين الإنفاق والدم
والكنز الذي سيستغرقه الأمر الذي
يقودني إلى الاعتقاد بأن فلاديمير بوتين
سيستمر في التنزه على
حافة الاحتمال ، سأستمر في أه
تعلم خلط الأوراق من أجل
القوى الغربية هناك  قد تكون أه
غزوات محدودة إما من الجنوب
قليلاً من الشمال أو من
شرق أوكرانيا لكن فلاديمير بوتين
لن يفعل أي شيء أه تعرفه
يوحد الغرب في رد ساحق
سواء كان ذلك بعقوبات أو
إضافية وكبيرة.  أه أه
إمدادات أسلحة إضافية
لأوكرانيا لن يأكل فلاديمير بوتين مئات
وآلاف من توابيت الجنود الروس القتلى
القادمين من
بلد تستعيده آلة الدعاية لفلاديمير بوتين
جزءًا من الأمة الروسية ،
فهم لا يعتبرون الأوكرانيين
منفصلين جدًا عن الروس.  سيكون هذا الأمر
سيئًا جدًا للعلاقات العامة
وربما يكون فلاديمير بوتين ذكيًا جدًا
لذلك ، فماذا تعتقد أن نية بوتين
هنا إذن ،
لوضع نية لا يزال من الواضح أن
إبقاء أوكرانيا في وضع قصير إذا كان بإمكانه
فعل ذلك من خلال الدبلوماسية الدبلوماسية القسرية
إذا كان بإمكانه استخدام شخصيات
مثل السيد شولتز أو الرئيس الفرنسي
ماكرون لإجبار أوكرانيا على
الالتزام باتفاقيات مينسك أه هذا
كل شيء من أجل الأفضل بالنسبة له
اتفاق مينسك هو أنك تعرف أه
إخضاع أوكرانيا بوسائل أخرى ،
فهو مصمم لإعادة الجمهوريات الانفصالية هذه
من دونيتسك
ولوهانسك إلى الجسد السياسي لكيف الأوكراني
حتى تعرف بشكل فعال
الوظائف باعتبارها كتلة على
المزيد من التحرك لأوكرانيا تجاه
الغرب أو الناتو ، وهذا
سيبقى ذهب فلاديمير بوتين ، ولذا
قد نكون مجرد حفر لمسافة
طويلة هنا قد تكون هذه مجرد
البداية